well I want to say congrats because
you're like turned into like a Bonafide
Superstar oh thank you so much and
you've had like a really long journey in
this music industry you've been through
deals where you know certain people
didn't get it and you've just kind of
just transformed into like
uh one of the you know artists on The
Forefront of this rap [__] so
congratulations I appreciate you a lot
thank you
um have you noticed like besides you
know obviously you're doing a lot of
shows you're doing a lot of festivals I
see you doing clubs you're in Vegas you
got you have Vegas residency right now
yeah I have um I have one with dress
right now uh before dress we did Jewel
in hakkasan so Tau group no but like
have you noticed like for you was there
anything that changed
in terms of like where you started to
kind of see like things finally really
like work out in a big way
like where in terms of like were you
like doing anything differently or was
it just like finally the kind of the
Stars like aligned you know I think it's
a little bit of both I think uh when
every every time you see like an artist
have a moment I think there's like a
wonderful team behind the scenes like
that's helping them be great and I also
think that the stars are aligning
um and what I've learned through those
moments is just to like be way more
confident with whatever it is I'm doing
and just be sure of it before I press go
because then it's like it's foolproof
for sure do you because I feel like
there was like a moment where
you had gotten off of RCA because you
were on RCA for a while yeah like four
and a half years maybe
um and then the rust record happened yes
and then I feel like after that it was
just over after that has been kind of
busy because we well actually it was
crazy because the best on Earth happened
and then the pandemic hit so we weren't
really like able to work
um best on earth like in the clubs when
it first came out we didn't even end up
performing it together until a year
later right so uh that changes things I
think as well
um there's a lot of songs that I think
would have hit like in a different way
had we been able to be outside and has
had the stars and learned at that time
but either way I'm super grateful for
how it all turned out because I'm just
like
so blown away like you your plans are
never going to be as good as God's plans
for real yeah I think like I was just
like thinking like damn you got a record
with Nikki and a record with J Cole like
two of the greatest of all time crazy
right yeah like do you ever like look
back and just think like damn the last
two and a half years have been like
kind of surreal like I gotta kind of do
you appreciate it yes absolutely oh my
goodness like everybody that knows me
knows like I'm heavy on prayer like I
talked to God like a million times a day
and I'm just super grateful like I'm one
of those people that I I've seen so many
moments like come and go for me so now
I'm learning to just be like way more
present in those moments and appreciate
them for what they are and not like I
seek no expectations when I put music
out I just be like all right I'm gonna
put this out and whatever happens
happens and it's always some amazing
stuff that happens and so I'm always
like
shocks me right tell me the story on how
uh because you've told it before but
like the London record is one of my
favorite joints you put out you did a
great job on that record thank you yeah
it was I [__] played the [__] out of
that on the radio
um but how does Cole end up on that
particular song where you're doing the
whole London thing it's crazy because uh
we went to the studio to go meet Cole
for a whole completely different song
and um before we were on our way out I
was like hey can I play you something
like I'm you know I'm working on my
project I want to play this song and
he's like yeah go ahead I press play and
he loved the song He's like I love this
song this is good like
um
I was like okay you know what that's
like he just seemed like he really liked
the song and I wanted to send it to him
like some random day so like two weeks
later I think a month later I said it to
him and I was like hey just sending you
this if you want to listen to it if you
want to check it out since you said you
liked it you listen to it and you're on
your bike ride at the gym like whatever
you want and um yeah it just ended up
working out like that like he ended up
liking the song enough that he wanted to
put a verse on it and I was so happy
about that because
like look at that verse it's like one of
my favorite verses of all time oh he
killed it he got off how could I just
seen this one or that one I could have
both oh my God he got oh he did not give
you the throwaway covers I know he has
those by the way I feel like every time
he gets on some [__] he bodies it he
does and I honestly wanted to I was like
yo I'm gonna go because when I first cut
the record London it was like a vibey
fun record like me and Aziz we just have
fun like if you know us we go to the
studio and we just try to have a good
time so we weren't over we don't really
try to overthink anything or try to make
a a hit or try to make a certain type of
record we just catch a Vibe so I wasn't
overthinking or like pushing my pen to
the to the bars like expecting to get J
Cole on that song So when he put his
verse on it I'm like I'm gonna go redo
my verse they're like he's like no no no
they wouldn't they told me not today
yeah that's kind of like uh cheating but
like yeah I was like bro like who who
thinks when they cut like a random
reference that Cole's gonna be on that
song yeah it's crazy I think that's
against like unsaid rappers too like if
you send a record in with your verse and
then it comes out and your verse is way
different
it's fine I think that I think that
might have been the root of the whole
like cannabis LL thing back but I didn't
do it because I didn't want to change
the the essence and the energy because
you know sometimes they got that a
certain like energy to them did like
anybody in London like feel like you
were appropriating their accent
I mean nobody said that to me but I just
wonder because everyone's so sensitive
these days and like you know I have a
shout to England the colonizers of all
colonized machine but
um I just wonder if they had like yo yo
what like you're taking our you know I
mean I got so much love in London such a
great record like I love London so much
and it became like my second like I want
to see like my second or third home
because I was traveling in London so
often around that time so when we when
it came time that I did London I was
just so inspired by the culture yeah so
I was just like how can I put this
culture in a song without trying to like
piss anybody off but still make it my
own